eon rae en france pour terminer accusé
de fraude fiscale la banque suisse ubs
est fixé sur son sort on fait le point
la cour d'appel de paris avec notre
reporter katia tactique la cour d'appel
a rendu son délibéré dans l' affaire
d'évasion fiscale de la banque suisse
ubs et même les avocats de la banque eux
mêmes n'ont pas bien compris le délibéré
alors de manière générale les peines
sont infirmées pour les cadres du ps qui
avait été condamné auparavant en
première instance à des peines de prison
avec sursis et des amendes et bien
certains ont été relaxés de l'infraction
de blanchiment et pour de la peine de la
banque c'est une autre affaire pour la
banque ubs français ça il ya une
affirmation partiel a été retenu la
complicité de blanchiment aggravé pour
une amende d'un million cent soixante
quinze mille euros en revanche pour ubs
à gué la maison mère suisse eh bien il
ya bien reconnaissance de la culpabilité
de démarchage bancaire aggravé de
blanchiment et pour cela la demande est
très faible seulement trois millions
sept cent cinquante mille euros elle
devra en outre verser à l'état français
800 millions d'euros la banque avait dû
au préalable à verser un milliard
d'euros qui vont être confisquée soit au
total près de 1,8 milliard d'euros a
versé par la banque et c'est une somme
bien moins élevé qu'en première instance
en février 2019 la plus grande banque de
gestion de fortune dans le monde avait
été condamné à payer en tout 4 5
milliards d'euros un montant record qui
avait fait date dans ce type d'affaires
je vous propose d'écouter la réaction de
denis chemla avocat de la bande suisse à
ceux des libérés j'ai pratiqué un succès
parce que la confiscation d'un milliard
est une confiscation qui n'avait pas été
demandé par le ministère public le
parquet n'a pas demandé cette
confiscation il n'y a eu aucun débat
devant la cour sur cette confiscation de
ce fait puisqu'elle n'était pas dans le
débat je pense pas que pour la justice
on puisse qualifier cette succès on
precinct autre débat oui enfin ce qui
gêne le plus ubs pour l'instant c'est
d'avoir une décision qu'elle ne comprend
pas mais une fois qu'elle l'a comprendra
elle verra ce qu'elle a à faire pourquoi
la somme demandée ubs est elle plus bas
c'est bien pour l'appel le parquet avait
requis une amende d'au moins 2 milliards
d'euros pourquoi parce que la loi avait
changé entre les deux procès et entre
temps la cour de cassation avait statué
que dans ce cas de figure la menthe doit
être calculée sur la base des impôts non
perçus et pas sur le montant faramineux
des comptes bancaires ouverts ce montant
à la baisse et surtout cette amende de 3
millions de 750000 euros à la place des
trois milliards 700 millions de première
instance ont scandalisé brad birkenfeld
ce lanceur d'alerté américain du
scandale d'évasion fiscale du ps estime
que c'est un signal encourageant pour
les fraudeurs de devoir payer si peu
qu'on les écoute
cela montre que la justice française ne
marche pas car le profit qu'ils ont fait
est bien plus important donc les impôts
se sont bien fait revoir ce n'est pas de
la justice aujourd'hui absolument pas
ils enfreignent la loi depuis des années
une baisse avait été accusé d'avoir
organisé entre 2004 et 2012 le
démarchage de ses clients français sur
le sol hexagonal c'est illégal par des
chargés d'affaires suisse et ensuite des
comptes ont été ouverts des comptes non
déclarés et puis s'est chargé d'affaires
était accusée de leur avoir conseillé
divers mécanismes d'évasion fiscale au
coeur de ce système des bonus au culte
pour s'est chargé d'affaires répertoriés
dans des documents secrets les carnets
du lait qu'ils étaient des fichiers
excel quoi qu'il en soit à la suite de
ce scandale mondial le secret bancaire
avait été enfin levé en suisse sauf pour
les résidents